so what's the deal of fortnight I mean
that's what we've all been asking
ourselves since the game was first
announced back in 2011 because since
then epoch has pretty much gone dark
until now at least see I got to play a
few hours of Port night recently and you
know what it's really fun it's also kind
of difficult to describe so let me do my
best
see fortnight is like a big wonderful
mishmash of a lot of different games
there's a bit of Team Fortress 2 in the
overall look of the world as well as the
way players have to choose between
distinct classes but this is a co-op
game so the ninja with his speed and
melee skills and the constructor with
his bulky frame and enhanced building
abilities they all need to work together
to get the job done now that job
requires searching through procedurally
generated levels for these glowing
portals which led in creatures from
another world and then using a device
called Atlas to shut them down which
well it's a process that attracts a
whole bunch of undead enemies unless
activated now defend the Atlas until the
gate has been closed so what you want to
do is defend the Atlas by constructing a
giant defensive Ford around it I'm
talking fortified walls stairs to get
you up to a sniping perch booby traps to
protect the perimeter the whole nine
yards but before you do any of that you
and the other three players on your team
need to run around scavenging for
resources that could mean knocking down
trees for wood finding treasure chests
tucked away on rooftop or really
anything in between scavenging is a huge
part of fortnight it's how you craft
crazy weapons how you restock on ammo in
a big fight and most importantly it's
how you build all those walls stairs and
ceilings to keep your torte secure
so that's fortnight in a nutshell
there's also a whole RPG style
progression system and because this is a
free-to-play game you'll also be able to
buy silly hats and card packs that give
you a random chance to earn new weapon
blueprints so for more on all that stuff
be sure to check out our extensive
written preview on GameSpot calm
you